[Music]
ted is standing by what an incredible
weekend perfect weather ted for
parades and fireworks and all the fourth
of july stuff a lot of pool time for a
lot of people so
thank you ted well done i'm here i think
i take checks it's fantastic
great weekend for barbecuing pool for
sure those temperatures were hot and of
course we didn't have any monsoon
moisture to ruin all the fun right so we
stayed
just hot for this weekend unfortunately
the heat is going to continue
for this week even hotter live look
outside tower cam
looking towards the south here you can
see mainly clear skies
our high today 108. 84 overnight for the
low 104
is our average and guess what we're
going to be way above that
all through the week okay 110 right now
in centennial hills 103. someone
106 aliente downtown north las vegas
you're currently 108
109 on the east side and also for green
valley and 106 for roads ranch and
mountains edge 109
also for henderson at this hour 105 for
prump
and death valley you're 116 with 111
followed by you down in lafayette those
are the hot spots here
in southern nevada and into california
there radar network showing dry
conditions right now we did we did see a
few pop-up storms still right there just
south
of sedona south of flagstaff nothing
here though as we remain dry
we do have some mid-level moisture that
snuck its way in that's why you're
seeing those clouds
and the humidity is not dropping or
hasn't really
gone up too much it still stayed in
about ten to even
eight percent humidity so very dry
conditions here storms still continue in
the four corners region
now the reason for the heat is this high
again okay so it's going to head up
overhead for us
as we get by midweek and then over to
the east a little bit friday could bring
up some moisture thursday and friday up
towards the region but
we think we'll stay on the dry side it
will start to migrate back
westward and as it does that our numbers
will start to drop
finally after the weekend we're also
tracking tropical storm elsa over cuba
right now should make landfall in the
big bend of florida here
we think on wednesday and then start
dying out but look at this sending its
moisture through the delmarva
all the way through the cape and even
the canadian maritimes there still
affecting much of the
eastern seaboard there through the week
86 overnight mostly clear and warm 110
for tomorrow very hot above average with
no record tomorrow that's 115.
we will come close to records though by
the time we get to wednesday
here are your neighborhoods 108
centennial hills 106
for mountains edge 109 downtown north
las vegas 100 for henderson
even hotter in death valley 122 tomorrow
here's your eight day forecast
increased clouds thursday and friday but
those numbers coming very close to
records and definitely
overnight records too as we get through
the hot
week that's your most accurate forecast